what kind of music do you like to play
uh pretty much everything i mean i was a
classical violinist growing up uh and
then i also play
fiddle and and celtic and country music
and uh
gotten into jazz and then i do
everything all the way to to playing
rock and electronic dancing wait and
things like that you can play rock music
uh on the
on the rocked music like what what kind
of what kind of rock are we talking
about yeah yeah or what woody and pretty
much anything anything led zeppelin they
could play some led zeppelin on the
violence christian kids
in my set here i do um guns and roses we
do
can we hear that please do you have one
is there any way we can hear it this is
fantastic this could be a violin you've
never seen before but this is oh my god
it's a flying v violin it's a yeah it's
the cool flying v
guitar but it's a violin that's so cool
look at that over his shoulder between
the straps
it actually makes more sense yeah as a
violin because the v
makes a crook that goes into your neck
that's fantastic yeah it was invented um
do you know the trans-siberian orchestra
they always have that big christmas yes
i've heard them before yeah they're
great so the the guy who was the
original electric violinist of that
group
invented this violin wow it looks like
one half of a shoulder pad that a
klingon would wear
yeah yeah
yeah i should get one on the other side
yeah i can do the double thing oh that's
cool uh so i want to hear something yeah
this yeah so i mean the way it can sound
pretty much like kind of like a normal
violin right like
[Music]
wow all right it's cool right then you
can do all kinds of great stuff with it
as well
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's fantastic it's fretted like a
guitar this is freddy yeah yeah this is
a fretted one too so
basically you're unfriendly you're not a
violinist you're a guitarist who's
pretending he's a violinist you're a
shoulder guitarist yeah i'm a shoulder
guitarist you have no idea how many
people say that on my videos do you uh
do you play any classics do you play any
classic solos in hard rock style yeah
hard rock side in hard rock style so i
mean i told you we do like
[Applause]
[Music]
uh i'll do some uh axle if you do your
part go ahead all right ready here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
memory
that's perfect all i heard in there was
mammary
it's like billy gibbs doing axel rose
yeah i always thought the lyric was
barry i'm having a problem with my gland
it's my mammary i thought that's what it
was have a problem with my gland it's a
memory